[Music]
I haven't seen my daughter and now her
daughter shows up at my front doorstep
but not a word
I think my parents are in some kind of
trouble oh Ashley's in trouble what is
it this time
get on that flight and do not come back
without my hard drive
purpose for your visit pleasure
lay low for a few minutes
welcome to the island I'm losing my
patience oh no no
[Music]
I just got out of it with my life did
you shoot me I guarantee you there's
more men that are already coming they
will not stop until we are all dead
come on Ashley
who are you
the old guy he keeps killing everybody
everybody
who is this guy
my dog's an assassin isn't he
your dad's totally unassette
[Music]
here have some more syrup sweetheart